journey to dunkirk started in
afghanistan he fled as the taliban moved
in and until a few weeks ago was in
ukraine but war once again forced him
out
this is now his temporary home
as you can see like it's a rough
situation in here
this is the you know every day they
bring the water in here
here you take the bod so as you can see
there are families there are kids all
over here
they're waiting like thousands before
them for a chance to take the final leap
into new futures
but their dreams are being rewritten by
the uk government
news that we broke to them
if they take us to africa what are we
going to do there there is no future for
us in africa we are from afghanistan i
was trying to become a translator so
from there you know from the taliban
took over the country so our life was in
danger with their determination
unfaltered their intentions remain
they'll keep trying to get across till
they succeed we still have to go like we
can stay in this country since we don't
know anyone here you know
everyone thinks about their future so in
england everyone like they give proper
rights to human beings they wait weeks
and months for opportunities like this
last october we watched around 80 people
board inflatable dinghies in broad
daylight
all of them made it across the channel
for years the uk and the french
governments have been battling to stem
the flow of asylum seekers arriving at
camps like these but this is a business
a form of organized crime a network of
people across the world preying on human
misery and a desire to get to the uk
the home office plans are said to be
directed at young men like shaffy but
they say the timing is callous
this doesn't make sense they're
welcoming all ukrainian people like
they're humans we're humans as well
there shouldn't be double standard in
the world the war has been started from
since 20th century in afghanistan
and they are suffering too much and now
in ukraine this is just started and
everyone is just thinking about
ukrainian people this is not fair for us
the european commission has slammed the
new policy as neither humane nor
dignified and for those a whisker away
from new beginnings this is no deterrent
just another hurdle to overcome
ashna harinag sky news in calais